i'm i'm i'm gonna i got i gotta i gotta
stop you right there bill and tell you
um
the the currency of the people is not
bitcoin oh
here we go i'm ready to fight can we get
in the ring
what you don't think shibuya you don't
think it's dogecoin
i think that it has really cool
characteristics like that's
that are fun and of the people but it's
not architecturally built for the people
it's architecturally built to screw
people over well hold on all right we'll
talk about that
but let me show you the story dogecoin
is up 12
000 since january here's how much money
you'd make if you invested a thousand
bucks in january
if you bought dogecoin at the beginning
of the year you've enjoyed massive gains
over the past four months
months a one thousand dollar dogecoin
purchase on january first
at a price of less than a cent per coin
would be worth
one hundred and twenty one thousand
fifty two dollars at wednesday's high of
69 cents
a gain of more than 12 000
my friend dogecoin let's go to the moon
it probably will be physically put on
the moon on a
on a thumb drive i would not be
surprised if he did that but hopefully
he'll also put
bitcoin maybe some mines tokens who
knows that'll be great but
you think dogecoin is is not it it's
it's
it for a purpose of entertainment
it's a meme it's fun but it's not it for
like
you know if you look at the the code of
it
it's not because it can it's inflating
it's it's not maintained it's not really
decentralized
it's it's just let's let's go one by one
how is it not decentralized
okay so um it's like one guy owns a main
mining system i'm gonna bring up a
the federal doge reserve the
government's gonna seize the guys mining
servers and then
so i'm just going to run through like
quick bullet points on on
doge so bitcoin is scarce there will
only ever be 21 million
doge is infinite the system is on track
to mend 14.4 million new doge each day
and 5.2 billion each year forever
okay it bitcoin's issuance this is from
the student alex gladstein uh who
knows a lot about bitcoin um bitcoin
dogecoin's issue issuance is
unpredictable it can
and has been altered uh bitcoin is
decentralized
as a result of robust architecture of
full nodes
um dogecoin is not decentralized bitcoin
has
how is it 90 central here's the other
thing about doge people are buying
doge on robin hood look don't buy crypto
on robin hood you don't even own the
crypto they're holding it you can't even
get
the crypto if you buy it on robin hood
so most people who are buying doge are
buying it on robin hood they don't even
actually
own the crypto this is why you have to
control your own wallet like it's fine
to use
centralized exchanges to take custody of
your crypto but
you need to set up your own wallet like
on mines.com if you check out
our wallet you set up metamask you
control your keys you control
your wallet coinbase while you do own
you do control your keys that's a that's
a non-custodial wallet
yeah but i mean these things like so
it's fun doge is fun
and it's a cool part of what's happening
like i like doge
but it's it's not a good thing to be
saying
can't they hard fork doge and then why
would you do that when you already have
bitcoin because doge
could be a currency so can it will it
is exactly right so what what what do we
hear kfc now takes does coin
yeah oakland a's are accepting doge
should kfc dude
this is what i'm saying it doesn't
matter if it's a box of kleenex
if people have confidence that the
kleenex will get them a cheeseburger
they will clamor
but you can't have confidence the doge
is going to retain its value you can't
have confidence the u.s dollar is going
to retain
you you can have confidence that bitcoin
is going to in the long term
based on the structure and and gold
and silver or palladium or whatever the
thing about doge
is that it is more like cash
and it has the confidence of the people
for a very silly reason
it doesn't matter people want it and
some people want to just have it for the
sake of having it
a lot too and that's why it's that's
what part of why it's retaining value
because a lot of people are holding doge
right and they're actually providing the
liquidity for the market for all the
whales who are dumping
so you know the the bag you know the the
the retail the people
are getting left holding the bags of all
the people dumping and
it's just it's it it's a joke
let it be a joke don't like it really
the
the structure it could be altered in the
future to become better like he was
saying you know it can
the the code can be altered but
there's not an active development team
around doge if why not there could be
if you've got a building in the middle
of manhattan that's just falling apart
eventually someone's going to be like
this is prime real estate
we can fix this up and make it something
better because everybody wants honestly
i hope so i hope that the development
energy around doge gets revitalized and
like you know similar in the way that
ethereum is run
like so bitcoin is arguably more
decentralized than ethereum but the cool
thing about ethereum is that it keeps
innovating
and they have decentralized governance
yeah what are what are they doing now we
were just talking about the other day
that in july
they're going to start deflating the
currency or something yeah
yeah they're introducing uh a new
proposal which
burns uh the base fee to the miners for
all the transactions so that so there
will be
a deflationary force in ethereum that
means ethereum we'll just start
skyrocketing in value
who knows it would be a pressure point
the the thing about ethereum is there's
so much
developer energy there's so many
decentralized apps like mines
that are getting that are leveraging the
ethereum network and we
we integrate bitcoin as well but you
know doze doesn't have that energy it's
fun
but it would be nothing without elon
let's be
let's be real it would not he is the one
to be worth two he's gonna go on he's
gonna go on snl
he's gonna people think he's gonna do a
dogecoin skit
it's gonna hit a buck and then the
whales are gonna bail out yes
so get ready for that and time it i
don't honestly sell before us
no i i disagree well hold on hold on
hold on not financially
i'm not i'm not gonna give up yeah no
advice to anybody i don't why why does
everyone say that could you get sued or
something
i you probably don't have to i don't
know everyone just says it yeah it's a
meme
yes uh here's what i'd say if you can
afford to keep your doge
you should in 2014.
is that one that's when doge came out
right was it 2014
i'm not sure i had at some point i don't
remember when
on some exchange i had thousands of doge
and i was laughing how stupid it was and
now everyone was laughing and it was a
joke and it was like such currency such
crypto wow whatever was ha
memes memes memes and then i was like
whatever and i
lost them i have no idea where any of
these coins are now
it's worth you know 60 cents or whatever
and i'm like it'd be sure great to know
what happened to those coins
but i said about everything i had a
computer with like bitcoin on it got
destroyed and didn't care and just threw
it away because it was like a dollar
worth of bitcoin that's not worth like a
couple hundred thousand dollars
and it's all gone so that's why i'm like
you know what
at this point there were there there
were some other currencies that i had
purchased a decent amount of like way
back in the day
because i was like at one at some point
in a few years one of these currencies
might go from like one cent to five
cents and i'll be really happy
and then i just got paper hints and i
was like
i just write that bitcoin and that's
which i'll get back to bitcoin and while
bitcoin has performed
beautifully over the past several years
there are some currencies that i wish i
held onto
because the gains were from like one
cent to like a dollar which is
way better than bitcoin was so now i'm
just kind of like you know man
maybe maybe uh we're seeing the dogecoin
memification or whatever but i'll tell
you this
i'm gonna keep it yeah yeah i just like
you're not gonna make the same mistake
you
you made the mistake before so you don't
i also don't have so much doge that i'm
gonna like
become rich off of it or or like become
poor off of it
it's like maybe if i had 10 million dogs
or something
i'd sell and be like i don't want to
play that game but i don't i have very
little
you know most people probably only a
little bit that's sort of
the thing that is sort of a sickness in
the crypto
space is actually people just trying to
get 10xs
right and and they're manipulators you
know the thing
that i love about crypto is that you're
sort of voting
with your resources so i don't like to
participate
in tokens that i just think that their
value is going to go up
it's not why are you giving energy to
that
so i'm not saying never you know maybe
there's a place for it but
bitcoin is changing how society works
and that's why it's an amazing thing to
put your money into it because you're
you're helping that happen we should set
up doge atms
yeah yeah i wouldn't be you can't stand
no i just can't it's so fake
it's such trash it's a it's a trash coin
it's the ultimate trash coin
elon musk is the ultimate troll yes
he's hilarious i love him and you think
elon has like a billion dollars yeah oh
yeah
he probably went his shoulders are
mining it oh really yeah he said it i i
saw it so you said
doge isn't decentralized well it's it
you know there are miners
but so it is partially decentralized but
it's it's not nothing compared to
bitcoin so it's a variant scale of of
how decentralized
is this token whenever you're looking at
a crypto right and certain cryptos are
more or less
like are there cryptos that are
completely centralized or like one
person can print
that's what a digital dollar would be so
here's here's the problem i see with
bitcoin though only 21 million coins can
never come into existence right yeah a
lot of them are already gone because
when bitcoin was valueless people didn't
care and lost them like that famous guy
who was searching a dumpster for a a
trash dump for his hard drive because it
had like
oh man by now that hard drive is
probably worth like 100 200 million
dollars but it was like it's worth now
two million dollars he needs to go find
that hard drive with his coins on it
so there's just the the natural decay of
bitcoin
that's good so that's deflationary but
right so over a long enough period of
time there won't be enough bitcoin no
you just you can split it up into 100
million units
satoshi which is the smallest unit of
bitcoin will just
appreciate in value so it's not i don't
think that the
there's there's plenty of divisibility
within bitcoin
so if bitcoin became universally adapted
around the planet with you know eight
billion people
and people need to trade with it every
day then satoshi would
have to be worth somewhere around like a
nickel he has a million
bitcoin or something satoshi satoshi
satoshi
right so and it's never moved it's never
moved and it's very important that it's
never moved
well because if people started to see
the
the creator you know getting paper hands
right that wouldn't be good well so
imagine bitcoin becomes universally used
right
one satoshi would have to be around the
value of a nickel or so
because you know as it stands today
to be able to participate in a general
marketplace uh or or labor
theoretically it could be around a penny
for satoshi
but i think that's people don't really
use pennies all that much
yeah but there's a lot of countries
where a penny probably does have a lot
more value
it doesn't really matter if we're using
the smallest unit like in comparison to
you know a fiat comparable i think like
right now
the bitcoin market's like a little over
a trillion the gold market cap for
reference is
10 trillion so if the bitcoin market
just gets to what gold is then we're
at like 500k per bitcoin so you just
started you start
thinking about bitcoin is like eating
away at
where resources are stored all we need
to do is 10x
to get at gold and then if you start
bringing in so all different financial
instructions
for bitcoin if it 10x is yeah i think
bitcoin will be a million bucks
oh for sure sometimes i think sooner
than people there's a model called the
stock to flow model which
is like the model of bitcoin and it
because every
four years the reward that there's this
thing called the having
which is where the mind happening or
either does it happen
either people say both but so the
rewards to all the miners
drop in half so you know it's basically
more scarcity it's more
no no it's just the the the ongoing
rewards that they get
for mining drop in half so it
you know they don't they don't
necessarily sell but it just creates
more scarcity and
historically there have been two having
so far
and after each half having you know over
the last 10 years
you've seen a order of magnitude and so
the stock to flow model shows that you
know over the next 15 years
it's going to be order when's the next
happening uh it was just a couple years
ago so it's like in a couple years
oh okay so then or maybe
a couple years it's gonna effectively
double so uh people often ask
what is what what backs about bitcoin's
value
and i don't know if this is like an
archaic understanding but it's the
energy used to produce it
so if somebody is mining bitcoin and it
costs them
you know sixty thousand dollars to mine
one bitcoin they're not going to sell it
for less than the cost of the production
so then they'll put it on the market and
say i gotta get at least 61k
and probably more than that and then
people who want to buy because they want
to use it
are going to have to pay the price of
what the miners are asking for yeah and
it's potentially going to do great
things for
sustainable energy like people say oh
bitcoin uses so much energy
it's like an environmental disaster
which it does use a lot of energy
it's it's a worth it is it kind of
arbitrary is it ethereum better
well no it's not better or worse they're
different technologies for different
purposes i mean you build apps on top of
ethereum bitcoin
is just like the juggernaut godfather of
ledger for global monetary transactions
that's all that it needs to be and there
are like layer two things happening so
that there will be other
you know apps potentially on bitcoin but
you know it's it's just crazy that this
is happening
it's actually you don't you don't you
think it's going to help the energy
situation well because people like
energy can be converted into bitcoin
so like there's you know that if they're
if you have a landfill and there's like
methane overflow like you could
potentially throw mine
on top of that i got it you know we
should do
we should create power plants that
recycle the heat from mining bitcoin to
boiling water and spending turbines
or we can put gpus
in people's homes that mine bitcoin and
the x and the radiant heat
will heat their room it's called it's
called exergy it's an actual
project yeah where your computer eats
water tanks we're just talking bill and
i actually visited a guy in new york
that was working on this
and um then the tubes will go through
your house these hot water
to cool down warm so well so you need
you need to cool your computer your
your cpu and your gpu need to be cooled
and so
the heat we want for warmth the computer
wants the cold
so hey there you go a lot of people say
like facebook has servers in the arctic
dude but that heat is valuable you just
need to recover it
yeah yeah people want to heat their
homes let's just do it with uh with
bitcoin mining
so in in winter you make money you're
like oh it's getting gold better make
some bitcoin
crank it up yeah no there i i predict
mining rigs in this
in this compound in the next few years
this compound i don't think so no
why it's easy just throw up a comp you
know
have fun yeah but you can figure it
there's
there's an roi so what what's ethereum
is proof of stake though how do they how
do you generate well they're not proof
of stake yet
right so they're transitioning if the
ethereum blockchain's still proof of
work like
bitcoin so these miners so how many
ethereum are there how much ethereum is
there uh
some people it's harder to pinpoint the
exact supply
um in ethereum it is it is sort of
limited
i don't know the actual number and a lot
of people
criticize ethereum for that reason
but that doesn't mean that it's like
very inflationary just the way that it's
set up it's it's harder to pinpoint the
ex
the exact number at any given time but
um you know they are they're they're
bringing in this deflationary force but
proof of stake is basically
where there are validator nodes all over
the world that people run the machines
you can run
on your laptop and if you have 32 eth
you can stake that eth into that
validate
validator node and basically earn
it generates more ethereum it gen yeah
you earn
you earn ethereum for for staking eth
into
validator nodes is it generating it or
is it a tr is a fee that you're getting
from the existing
amount of ethereum both
both well your j miners
i'm i might be wrong here but miners are
earning fees
for all the transactions that are
happening in the network that's gas and
ethereum and bitcoin miners
actually in bitcoin after all of the
mining rewards
are over which is in like 100 years or
something then fees are going to be
uh rewarding all of the miners but
that's how it works in ethereum now but
there are there are also ethereum
that are are getting created
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you